this room has put the pain in painting
but because I put the mental
in mental health
and I don't know how to stop when I'm fixated on something
so far I've tried five different colours
first it was the mustard limoncello combination
which actually sounds kinda delicious
then we tried a soft terracotta
then I gave up and we painted everything white before
I tried again and thought maybe we'd go tonal with a deep brown
a lot of people have commented telling me the orange wood is ugly
and I just need to white wash it
and a previous version of me might have to be honest
but I actually like it! it's super retro
has tons of character and it feels like
the heart and soul of the home
so I'm gonna challenge myself to make it work
so I found some inspiration
put together a mood board
cause by the way
that stone sample is actually gonna be my fireplace surrounds one day
and filled with blind confidence
cause you know I'm a big fan of positively gaslighting yourself
I took off to Dulux
and this might make you shake your head
but I didn't even sample it
I just fkn committed which is probably
you know
the sort of behaviour that got me into this situation in the first place
but what even is life unless it's slightly spicy
plus I had a really good feeling that this
colour was gonna be the colour
never mind the fact that I also had that feeling over the other five colours
if you don't already know
one thing you should know about this room
is it's actually two rooms in one
and one half
a half that you can't see gets a shit ton of natural light
and this half doesn’t
so I needed to find a blue that was blue
enough that you could tell it was blue
but dark enough that it was still Moody
but not too dark that it just looks black
you know
and if you've watched any of my other renovation content
you will know I'm a big fan of a deep green
and a lot of people suggested painting this room green too
and you're right it would look lovely
especially with that orange wood
But the room directly off this one is my dining room
and I've already painted that one green
and as much as I love green
I don't want every room to be green
do you know what I mean
K not a word of a lie
this next part had me sweating
cause as much as I love the heritage wood
I don't love it everywhere
and there is a lot in the house
so
I got rid of some of it
But it made this other half look more like a feature wall
which I love
up next we're cleaning this room within an inch of its life
so come back for the update